welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of Marvel
Studios I IM Groot season 2 all five
shorts these are filled with MCU Easter
eggs and details you missed and I know
this might come off as an MCU title that
you can skip but trust me while some of
it is totally silly goofball nonsense
there are some big moves this show makes
that I believe makes IM am Groot more
required viewing than secret invasion
was you know pretty low bar but we all
rolled our eyes at what if and that show
it been hugely important and in this
case watching these short it's will only
take you like 20 or 25 minutes come on
watch them have some fun come back here
and watch us breakdown okay let's start
with season 2 episode 1 are you my Groot
as with season 1 this short begins with
Groot fast forwarding through the Disney
plus Marvel Studios Fanfare and then
looking at the camera and knocking it
over and the Marvel Studios title card
turns into artist brush Strokes as it
does in what if and if nothing else this
season of I am Gro does set up season
two of what if which sounds like it's
going to come this Christmas and just so
we're clear these I am Groot shorts are
all set between Guardians volume 1 and
in volume 2 in that kind of era when
Groot was still in his baby Groot stage
so really just a reminder that Thanos
has not killed Gamora yet Disney Plus's
timeline playlist puts it after Volume 2
so you know maybe at this point yandu is
dead but in season 2 episode 4 Groot is
on the ravager ship the eclector which
blows up in volume 2 so it's almost like
whoever Marvel put in charge of their
timeline maintenance needs to be pruned
by the DVA I'm sure that timeline book
that's coming out will have zero errors
whatsoever because Marvel Studios
definitely knows what it's doing when it
comes to its chology anyway Groot is in
a jungle area on this planet called
terma and we know it's terma because the
birds he finds in this episode are terma
birds according to the credits terma was
one of the planets that showed up in
Rocket's tablet in volume 2 in the
comics terma is the planet where quazar
and moon dragon found Adam Warlock and
stasis it's kind of a throwaway Planet
but now Guardians vol 3 just introduced
PHA who becomes quazar so this stuff
might come into play Groot Wears Like a
sling backpack this hip fanny pack with
matching colors to the Milano so this is
probably Peter quills I know you
Watchers in the UK have a different take
on the word Fanny but you know that's
your weird problem Groot snacks on candy
that I think is the same space candy
that he eats and then pukes up in volume
two this turup bird
hatches we hear a sound like it's a
magic trick and I love whenever the
director Kristen leapor frames Groot
from below because normally Baby Groot
is Tiny in frame but from his point of
view sometimes they're just things even
smaller than him and by Framing it this
way it creates this cool sense of scale
where we can really make out the details
of groots anatomy and also just kind of
freaks us out now the title of this
episode are you my Groot is probably a
reference to PD espins are you my mother
which is edited by the Dr Seuss brand
and yeah the story kind of goes the same
way as the kids book does like Elliot
with ET grp be friendis bird really just
on the basis of candy but overall this
is a bunch of poop jokes I'm kind of
glued to my computer most of the day so
I wind up ordering a lot of stuff for
delivery and this morning I got an iced
coffee for my favorite local place for
free by using a Visa gift card that I
got from answering surveys on ipsos iay
ipsos isay lets you earn extra cash
through gift cards and rewards just by
taking part in research and answering a
few simple questions there's a ton of
different gift cards to choose from but
my favorite is the Visa I can use it
anywhere for anything which gives me the
most options to pick out free stuff for
myself the surveys on IPOs I say are
quick easy and tailor to my interests so
it never gets boring I do them while I'm
brushing my teeth or stuck on hold or
just have a few minutes to kill I
upgraded my downtime and you can too
just click the link in the description
to start earning rewards with ipsos I
say today the bag of candy reads in the
scroll language in lower case candy
which I'm glad I could clear up for you
as Groot tries to sleep the goofy music
slows
down and then a whole bunch of other
terma birds Stampede pass Gro they're
really headed though to the Giant M
terma bird which somehow defying the
laws of physics flaps away with just
these tiny wings and now when Groot
steps in the Poo he can't help but feel
a bit nostalgic and the credits of all
these episodes are these disclaimers in
this one it reads no tree creatures
terma birds or big mamas or harm during
the making of the short okay onto season
2 episode 2 Groot noses around Groot
plays a video game while stuffing
himself silly on junk food this is a
fighter game in the style of Street
Fighter and it looks like Groot is
playing as a scroll Fighter fighting
against either a blue Celestial or maybe
just a creas soldier and cheering from
the background more Easter eggs Howard
the Duck and Valkyrie and I think maybe
on the far right that might be topaz
from sakar I'm not really sure though
now already in this junk covered room
there is a layer of green stench
hovering over everything we see it but
we don't notice it because we don't
smell it yet the game pauses and a
window pops up with cre letters
translating to Bow battery so Groot
looks through a bin marked rocket stuff
keep out and he finds One battery but
also in this bin is bork's eye that's
the eye that rocket wanted in volume one
and showed back up in volume two there's
a yellow robot arm maybe for the sex
spots of contraxia but then in the back
a metal leg with a shoe this is the leg
that rocket wanted Peter Quill to get
from that prisoner in the Kil in volume
one that he really didn't need root ends
up with an orange nose stuck to his face
giving him the ability to smell for the
first time he smells an air freshener
which is a tree like himself now I know
from the ice cream truck that the first
and the fifth letter that look like an
equal sign translates to e and the
second and the last one is an O and then
none of the other letters are i c r a m
or F that's the farthest I can get with
translating this Groot Huffs a
highlighter and tries to eat a candle
and he sprays himself with deodorant
this can has machine Builder code text
that translates to kill at the top of it
and then at the bottom the word clean
Groot returns to his room to realize how
horrible it smells but rather than using
the duster to clean he just uses it to
pop off the nose and he resumes his
plane and I love how the squirrel
fighter in this just got a big old smile
in the credits of this episode no tree
creatures were harmed during the making
of this short although robotic body
parts may have been borrowed for use all
right season 2 episode 3 groes snow day
the Milano heads to this ice covered
planet with terrain similar to the
planet where Thor and corg found fagar
the Behemoth and Thor love and thunder
Groot pours some cocoa in a mug from a
packet with scroll writing translating
to chock C H O C and then pour some
cream on it from a purple bottle
translating to cream outside Groot
throws a snowball at one of the rockets
on the Milano the cre text along the top
of it reads danger Groot makes a Snowman
and then decides to gather parts from
the Milo to decorate him including one
of those Rockets with a danger on it for
the head and then I love this at least
three anulax batteries anulax batteries
these are the ones stolen by rocket from
The Sovereign in volume 2 and they are
highly explosive highly valuable and I
speculated in my deep dive of Guardians
vol to these batteries might be based on
Celestial DNA Celestial tissue the same
Golden Fluid harvested from nowhere
which could be why when Groot plugs
these into the Snowman the snowbots to
life with a kind of sentience which
would fuel my theory that anyx batteries
have some deeper significance and deeper
power that have not yet been fully
realized in the MCU root throws a
snowball and it does no damage but it
does give the snow bot another idea to
pack more and more snow onto itself
making itself bigger into an alpha Snow
Bot and then when that snow bot turns
into Milano Groot fears not for for his
friends inside but for the steaming hot
coco and so Groot throws one last
snowball at the rocket in its head and I
love how Kristen leaport animates this
throw with a cheesy 80s action frame
rate the snow bot explodes and its red
eye stays illuminated like the
Terminator coming back to life there's
actually a post credit scene to this
episode as Gro sips the Coco and it's
still too
hot dude yeah a little vocal came up
from Bradley Cooper there as Rocket but
off screen now in the credits of this
episode no tree creatures were harmed
during the making of the short we cannot
speak for the Killer snowbots episode
four groot's sweet treat so Groot plays
with a can with a green label and a Nova
pilot action figure and I know I'm so
sorry because my trailer breakdown for
this I had a major brain fart and said
that this was a Steve Rogers action
figure and everyone yelled at me anyway
yeah this is a Nova pilot action figure
are we all happy can we move on please
okay so an ice cream truck floats up to
the eclector and it plays a classic ice
cream truck tun it's got choplin the
Entertainer the pink neon sign spells
out ice cream and I just kind of did
that through letter substit tion that's
how I was able to start to figure out
that air freshener there is a sign in
Builder machine code for flow cubes flow
cubes there's also an ice cream cone
that I'm pretty sure is based on Howard
the Duck there's a yellow bag with a
blue faki you remember faki that's a
species blurp is and we saw a hairless
one that looks like this fighting in
nowhere in volume one the text on this
screen is the same as the ice cream sign
in the air freshener it translates to 4
fre Groot traces a heart in the window
fog and in the center of that heart is a
popsicle in the shape of the cel aim the
judge his six-eyed head this is one
Groot wants so yes this tells us that
aim is famous enough around the Galaxy
that he being made into ice cream but it
makes us wonder why this one Groot we
answer that at the end of this breakdown
so Groot searches the eclector for any
kind of gold coins that he can find and
he finds the claw machine game with
machine Builder code on the outside of
this machine too the word win and gr
even though he's small enough to go
through the receptacle or even to reach
his Branch arms up through it he just
cannonballs through the glass and he
finds the coin is just ch chocolate
which I just have to pause here to ask
Groot this is chocolate you want a sweet
treat right just eat this so once he
finds all the coins Groot Pilots a ship
out of the eclector to catch up with the
ice cream truck and obliterates it
apparently because we end the episode
with Groot licking the AEM popsicle as
he howed the duck ice cream splatters on
the ship and he's surrounded by the
wreckage of the poor ice cream truck and
I hope this was autopilot because uh yes
someone would be dead and grot is
approached by two Nova core ships so
this episode opens and closes with Nova
and we end with the music of the
platters only
in the credits no tree creatures or
Intergalactic ice cream ships were
harmed in the making of the short all
sweet treats were thoroughly sampled and
tested for safety reasons and finally
season 2 episode 5 Groot and the great
prophecy now this one is a pretty huge
deal so listen up kiddos Jeffrey Wright
returns as a watcher the Milano flies
past his head and we hear him saying I
Am The Watcher your guide through the
vast realities of
time and today we bear witness to a
Monumental prophecy about to be
fulfilled so even though I IM Groot is
an animated title all the locations
creatures hardware and other things are
really things in the live action MCU
that would be rendered with 3D CGI so we
could look at this as a live action
title and that would make the Watcher in
this story background live action in a
sense which would be the second
liveaction Watcher Cameo after their
appearance in the Stan Lee scene in
Guardians Volume 2 so the Watcher
explains the legend of the last seed of
dresler dresler also showed up on
Rockets t in volume 2 in the comics drar
is a colony that's part of the cre
Empire it was destroyed in the
annihilation War which I think is going
to be partly adapted for the upcoming
film the Marvels but in Nova number four
in 2007 Nova Prime Richard Ryder comes
across Corell who led a group of 102 cre
survivors that were the only ones left
after 19 million colonists on Dres they
all got caught in enemy fire one two
left so the xandarian world mine merges
with Corell making her Nova 00001 but
Corell ends up failing and ultimately
dying thus the story of drar here drar
is a home of an ancient people who
worshiped this great seed that the
Watcher explains will emerge from this
hollowed ground according to the
prophecy and user the universe into a
glorious new age now this idea of a seed
of such Cosmic importance reminds us of
two things the emers of Genesis from
what if Episode 2 that was the M up of
that episode but also the idea of a
Celestial seed remember those that's
what aim would plant inside of plets
like Earth to grow and hatch into other
celestials like tiut this dresler seed
could be a Celestial seed in its gold
Golden Glow could be connected to the
celestial brain fluid and the anax
batteries if you buy my crackpot Theory
the chosen one hero of this story is of
course Groot he enters the temple
bouncing a purple Ball recalling P quill
dancing like a fool into the Morag
Temple there to contain a ball
containing an infinity stone the purple
Power Stone so in the way that was Peter
Quill's origin story this is kind of
groot's origin story you could say and
of course both of these are based on the
opening to Raiders of the Lost Arc but
rather than avoiding all the booby traps
Groot recklessly sets off every single
one of them including the release of
lava we realized this seed was actually
in this kind of maze so that the lava
flow would be timed perfectly to give
Groot as much time as possible to save
the seed but instead Groot gets
distracted by the mural and the
Watcher's eyes we see are glowing from
the upper right the vines perfectly in
the shape of his silhouette but Groot is
uninterested in the seed because he just
uses chalk to draw a face on the tree
because he considers trees to be
sentient and he's not wrong The Watcher
Frets he must be ready to resume his
mission the Galaxy's greatest hope has
only minutes until it literally go go up
in flames and can can he see me no I'm a
fifth dimensional being so Groot can
perceive The Watcher it's a huge deal
normally The Watcher can only be seen
when he wants lower light forms to be
able to see him with the exception of
Ultron infinity and the final two
episodes of what if Ultron Infinity had
all six Infinity Stones and was able to
elevate to this God level power akin to
something like Galactus because we saw
him take a bite out of a galaxy now
Groot as a species is a Floric Colossus
but I have long spe speculated that this
Gro after his former forms destruction
volume 1 came back as a being benefiting
from photogenesis via Celestial light
that could explain his affinity for the
aosm popsicle Groot could be a God and
not know it by the way fifth dimensional
being what would those five Dimensions
be well three dimensions of our reality
the X the Y and the Z axis for normal
three-dimensional space the fourth
dimension would be time The Fifth
Dimension would be beyond that according
to the Watcher that next Dimension would
be reality making him a being that can
transcend the Multiverse so you got
space time and reality which The Watcher
mentions in the intro to every episode
of what if so Groot gets his ball back
and he just lets the seed burn
supposedly dooming this universe as The
Watcher says I Am The Watcher but I
can't watch this yeah we see his eye
closing on the scene but it opens on the
rebel and he makes the realization
prophecy was so clear it said the seed
this small vessel of great potential
would Sprout from this very Place
spreading peace and joy throughout and
the sea is is a metaphor isn't it yes
Groot is a seed and yes it's probably
just a sweet tale to paint Groot as a
big thing in a small package inspiring
people like us with joy and happiness
but I think it also endows this
character with greater significance to
Future MCU events he's one of the
Guardians of the Galaxy who still seems
to be part of the Guardians lineup he is
now Alpha Groot and who knows what v
he's going to take next he could be
someone who actually makes a case for
life in general against celestials and
galatis he could Bridge the divisions
between universes during Secret Wars
Groot really could be the key to
everything because as The Watcher in the
clouds watches the Milano depart he
recognizes a goodness in Groot and Groot
recognizes him go forth you Little
Seedling I know you'll make us
proud how does he keep doing that yes
groot's Godly status his ability to see
through these Dimensions confounds even
other God figures like The Watcher who
remember in Thor love and thunder was on
the same tier of power as figures like
Eon death the celestial one above all
and eternal eternity and to The Watcher
Groot is a mystery to him so if you're
comparing two Mysteries when one mystery
is more mysterious to the other mystery
which of the Mysteries is more powerful
and in the credits of this episode we
see no tree creatures drar seeds or
ancient temples were damaged or lost
during the making of the short the same
cannot be said for a certain fifth
dimensional being's patience thank you
for watching this breakdown of I am
Greek season 2 please subscribe to all
three channels in the new rockstars
Network you can follow me on all social
platforms at eaos thanks for watching
and I'll see you next time
bye
[Music]
oh